that restlessness that belief that
tomorrow's more exciting than today you
know you just have to have it permeate
the organization complacency doesn't
just kill big businesses
it kills small businesses too I like to
be very competitive I like to pour
boiling oil over my competitors and
think every day how can I kill rise and
shine it's in spresso time good-morning
believe nation it's evan my one word is
believe and i believe in you i believe
you have an amazing gift inside to you
that i want to see exploded onto the
world so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message always be competing
over to you Warren Buffett well what
kills great businesses if you look at I
do believe in looking at history I like
to study failure actually and my partner
says all I want to know is where I'll
die so I'll never go there and and we
want to see what has caused businesses
to go bad and the biggest thing that
kills them its complacency I mean you
you want a restlessness a feeling that
you know that that somebody's always
after you but you're going to stay ahead
of them you always want to be on the
move and and when you've got a great
business you know like coca-cola wishes
there aren't any like oh girl but but
really the danger would always be the
you rest on your laurels but I see none
of that obviously a coca-cola but that's
that that is the key to to compete the
same way when you've got 1.8 billion
servings being sold daily as when you
were selling you know 10 a day and and
that restlessness that belief that that
tomorrow's more exciting than today you
just have to have it permeate the
organization complacency doesn't just
kill big businesses it kills small
businesses too it's likely gonna kill
your business as well what happens with
so many entrepreneurs is the beginning
of our companies we're so passionate we
have an amazing idea we want to go off
and build this company and we're working
really hard we don't want to work for
the main we don't want to have a
corporate job anymore and so we create
our own opportunity and it's exciting
and it's different and it's new but then
what ends up happening is for so many
people we get bored of our businesses
because we keep doing the same thing
over and over and over and over again
and so that can be really boring
especially if you get some kind of
success with your company it's easier to
get bored of it because you're not
making any changes because whatever let
you do that success you keep doing it in
the exact same way because you don't
want to kill the Golden Goose you don't
want to change up your plan because you
know this is working but especially for
entrepreneurs we like variety
we crave different things and
as we grow and evolve as a human your
business needs to grow and evolve as
well and so complacency kills every
business kills every industry and the
way to get through it is as you grow and
evolve as a person you need to bring
that to your business as you change in
your mindset and your beliefs as you
want to explore new paths you need to
bring that to your business because if
you don't you're gonna slowly go out
here right it just happens you are not
the same person you were when you were
25 the things you cared about the things
you're interested in the things you want
to explore and go and create are
different but if your business is still
here then the further out that you grow
the unhappy you're gonna be in your
business and so the key is you need your
business to catch up to you you need to
grow and evolve with it I use YouTube as
an example my youtube channel is always
a reflection of me of what I'm
interested in if you go back on the
content way in the early days it's not
exactly the same as it is now as I come
up with a new idea I want to bring it to
my channel I want to bring it to you
guys I want to see what you think of it
I want to see how it can explode
potentially into your lives and make a
big impact as soon as I get an idea I
need to go and test it out if I wait if
I sit on it if I get frustrated with it
and I feel like I can't bring it to my
business that's when my business starts
to feel like a job if I ever stopped
like in YouTube which I'm sure what
happened at some point if I don't want
to make videos anymore the day that this
becomes a job like oh I got to show up
and I got to make videos I'm filming
lots of videos here today for you the
day that this is a job as a day that I
quit
is it a move on to something else
because you will never win doing work
that you hate most entrepreneurs wait
too long for that to happen they wait
for this big break to happen or what you
want to do is every time you grow you
bring your business with you so it never
becomes this big crazy initiative I look
at people in the YouTube community - and
they're complaining about the algorithm
updates and they're complaining about
how YouTube isn't the same as it was
before and their videos aren't doing as
well YouTube is an amazing platform the
way that it worked in the first number
of years is not the way that it works
now and all the big youtubers what they
did was they stopped evolving they
stopped growing they stopped injecting
more of their art they're doing it the
same way they were doing it five years
ago
and that's not the way to win anymore
and I love it when people complain I
love it when people complain about how
things have changed because the only
constant has changed you can continue to
expect your industry to change always
and I love it when the people ahead of
me are complaining because I see that
that's my opportunity if the people with
10 million subscribers are complaining
and they're slowing down and they don't
want to evolve and change their business
that's great for me because I'm going to
continue to change I'm gonna continue to
evolve and I continue to bring that to
you guys
and so complacency kills businesses the
day that you start getting bored with
your company you have two options one
sell it or find a way to evolve it the
worst thing you can do is try to hang on
try to hang on
try to hang on because you will lose
because the people who love their
business who are in the same industry as
you will crush you because you have no
hope of going up against somebody whose
absolute in love with the company when
you hate doing what you're doing so stop
being complacent and continue to evolve
your business as you evolve as a person
now we got a special bonus clip for you
but before getting to that my question
of the day for you is I want to know
what is one thing that you are bored of
in your business that used to excite you
but now you're bored of it and you need
to let it go leave it down in the
comments below I'm curious to see what
you have to say thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso and enjoy the bonus
when it comes to winning in business I
like to be very competitive I like to
pour boiling oil over my competitors and
think everyday how can I kill because
that is the war of business ultimately I
want my shareholders to make more money
than my competitors and that's very
healthy so I think the DNA of a business
has to be how do you make money how do
you spend your time making money for
shareholders here and your nobody is an
entrepreneur until you've made money for
somebody else
I think ego and like people wanting to
be the best people the Orson Welles
personality I think that's cool and
really III encouraged like 25 year olds
to like inflate their egos as large as
they can and compete with each other
because they're doing it for the
audience the audience wins like that
that's the way it should be a bunch of
like you know creatives saying I'm the
best no I'm the best and I'm better than
you I'm better because they're like
gladiators and there should be a stadium
of people around them winning every
every time if we're going to compete in
a segment in any market we're gonna go
to win I think that was a change for
General Motors and frankly the team has
rallied around that because everyone and
whatever industry or business you go to
people want to go and do their best so I
feel so much of what I need to do is
just set up the systems and able the
processes and have the right leadership
that our designers and our engineers and
our buyers can go do the best work they
can do every day and like I said I you
know a simple thing I said it was no
more crappy cars and that resonates you
know said okay yeah you're I mean I
think there was some time so many
boundaries put on them that we we didn't
give them a recipe for success so now
we're saying hey no excuses you know I
don't if it's budget if it's resources
we have to do great cars trucks and
crossovers and and it's our job to
enable you to do that and it's it's
really been a transformation raise your
standard Apple that's a cool it's core
value is that
not one drop of myself work depends on
your it's something Sammy
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details